so good to see all of you oh my gosh
i watched your show last night and let
me tell you when i see loretta pulling
up the belt and i was like thinking
about
it and how things have changed man
it's it's a journey watching the show
but uh
do you think we've become softies i'm
going to send this off to you today or
are we doing it right
as parents now in 2021
you know i don't think we've become
softies okay
see so you know it's it's that tradition
versus non-tradition
right i don't think we've become softies
i think we just now know more
like you know my mother she used to
spank me when i was
was a child but i it just doesn't work
for me because
it's just i i don't i don't
i don't want to be it's more about
the mind feeling for me it's harder to
you know it's easier to spank in my
opinion huh
what listen kids are running down and
explain you know to your children about
why
the easy thing to do is just spank your
kid like to be like
not to do that and just thank them but
it's hard to explain to your kid and
have to sit down and
okay mommy said not to do that because
you know and so that's
it's tougher so i think exactly and and
you know sometimes
and sometimes when parents are like you
know working two or three jobs you know
they're tired
yeah and you know the first thing that
they want to do
is that they react by you know spanking
their children and that's just not the
way
i choose to do it but you know after
that first good spanking
you put a spanking investment in the
investment
and then it looks
loretta what's your look give me the
look that you would give if your kids
are in trouble
all you have to do is look at them yeah
that's it
i know that look
[Laughter]
and go sit in the corner see how good
you turned out to you those weapons
come
you are living proof that's a game just
have a bunch of celebrity girl across
the screen is like spanked
that is true that is true that is
true yeah you and i are living proof
that's right i guess that's
that's true oh man all right and anthony
matt the fact that your character is a
football player
uh it kind of reflects your own life
that you're going through is it strange
to kind of bring that storyline to this
this show and kind of reflecting on all
of it
no i mean it's it it kind of it fits you
know it fits really well and it's
the good thing is that i have
experiences to pull from so it makes it
uh really authentic and it makes it feel
uh authentic to me and so that just
helps
everyone when you're watching it that
you know i'm just in the pocket with it
so
it it it's always it's always nice to be
able to pull from your own personal
kind of memory and experience to to
bring them to light so i was really
happy when i saw that moe's was an
ex-football player
are you going to play some football in
the sierra in the show
let's hope not because i'm not i'm
retired now
i'd rather sit and talk
and lauren i just want to say you are
amazing i've been watching for years and
years you've had so many amazing roles
through your career and
and you tend to play a lot of moms so
what has been your favorite role
always my i always say my favorite role
is the role i'm doing
presently because a lot of them i can't
even remember
so uh i've had roles that changed my
life
waiting to exhale changed my life you
know preacher's wife i got to work with
uh yeah
denzel again there's so many things that
i could say of favors but then i've done
so much on tv that is memorable to me
uh eli stone was a tv show that that
went out before his time carmichael's i
could just go on and on so yeah
thank you thanks guys i'm getting a wrap
already i feel like we just got started
but uh congratulations on the show
and uh i think it's gonna be such a
blast for all the family to watch
we need this in our lives so thank you
so much
you